[Music]
three two one action hey guys welcome
back to off-the-record where we talk
about whatever we want and today we have
Clark Jones here he is a stand-up
comedian and also the host of classic
black dude yes
CBD oil said it now dude that's tight
before we get to that so thank you to
our sponsor native deodorant native
creates simple safe and effective
products that people use in their
bathroom everyday native deodorant is
formulated without aluminum parabens and
talc and uses ingredients found in
nature such as coconut oil shea butter
and tapioca starch and native is never
tested on animals so they're not trying
to put it on dogs thank God yeah making
the switch to aluminum free deodorant
does not mean having a sacrifice on
product performance native has over nine
thousand five star reviews it comes in a
variety of scents for men and women such
as coconut and vanilla lavender and rose
and cucumber and mint
they also have an unscented formula in a
baking soda free formula for those with
sensitivities for 20% off your first
purchase visit native deodorant calm and
use promo code OTR during checkout
there's no risk to try made of offers
free shipping as well as returns and
exchanges in the USA again for 20% off
your first purchase visit native
deodorant calm and use promo code OTR
during checkout think your native thank
you yes I'm great I'm great things are
things are going well happy to be here
at Monterey Park can I shout out will
yup no stalkers no you yeah okay
actually how about this when I interview
people for my companies yeah I usually
ask them one of these questions what's
something that you're very embarrassed
about that you've never told anybody
give me give me like a category yeah
things I like to enjoy Zappa one of the
people that we interviewed told me that
it's a secret don't say that one but
that I'm not talking
it doesn't matter them about me anymore
I know but you can't say it no can't say
see it's just [ __ ] up cuz we said what
we're gonna say anything can I know what
about to say no damn Danny I got a good
yeah well Selena you answer your
question just my own questions you
asking me yeah what is the most what was
the question what is the missing
embarrassing that you've never told
anybody yeah see even you get thrown off
hard so much [ __ ] here that it's like
nice to pain you guys every time like
that you guys know more about me than I
probably remember and as a stand-up is
hard because I talk about everything the
more embarrassing it is my oh [ __ ] I
could use that
yeah what's something that you did then
that girls would be like now suck is
dead I mean like something dope that I
yeah oh my god I mean I don't know if we
girls suck my dick for this but there's
probably something one that well this is
Rick this is real this is a real
business real thing and I'm you know I
do make jokes about it but I recently
had to take care of my mom because she
was diagnosed with ovarian cancer Oh No
so how do you make jokes about that well
I use Frankie does a kid like really bad
with my wit will work me as a kid and
like so because she was weakened I was
like damn what could have took this leg
[Laughter]
[Applause]
cancer hit a little bit earlier I could
have done cuz I stole some candy I
remember I got the words loaf and a ball
I'm like man this cancer strength is
it's more insufferable you know why
could she get cancer earlier yeah
exactly
not not something dire but like a
beatable one if you want an answer to
your first question if a girl would suck
your dick or not if they heard that yeah
let's say they're probably not yeah but
but I'm saying my experiences going I
went home last week and I just was
basically my mom's in the house like
nurse for two days
that's Dixon with helping the walk and
helping her get dressed and I just just
a hole from 0 to 60 I didn't do any
shows I was a no social media anything
you know just like whatever you need I'm
here for you man
that's a good man actually the first
people I thought that says I'd be like
tough luck mom
no I just it's it's hard me mama me and
my mom we're SuperDuper tight no I'm the
youngest though so like yeah you don't
have any siblings
I do but like that's immediately what I
do it's it's hey moms in trouble right
go get her all right so my brother's
been he's a nurse so he's nurses are
busy other people think every door that
sends miles away I was just like you
know I I got to I gotta go I just went
to the airport and just waited for it
taken to open up and I just flew to [ __ ]
all were you like hey isn't this funny
how you used to wipe my ass and now I'm
wiping your ass it didn't I thought
about it but you know what in a moment
here's the thing even like people always
like you know I'm not ready to be a
parent or some like that I'm too selfish
and I was but something something kicks
in when you have to do what you have to
do so to where like you're thinking I
mean I'll never do that that's crazy
yeah but like in a moment somebody you
love me something yeah all that far that
the length weather balloon you're not
even thinking like about I mean it's in
retrospect oh my god I can't believe oh
my how many gloves you have me go so
just like roll up my sleeves
literally roll up my sleeves and do it I
had to do that's love man that's those
guys in his purest form
my mom is the reason why I know how to
love another person because I take that
all the things that she did for me just
like I mean I could be here all day
talking about me and my mom's
relationship but all the things that
she's taught for me I look at how I
treat other people I care about
and I'm like oh this is so like if they
don't get that then that's usually when
we don't work out as a couple if they
can't take the type of you know
overbearing like you being something
I'll make sure that you're physically
safe and all of that I wish I had a
black woman in my life
you need one at least ones my mother
took me out of love at all either by
myself going black Twitter and moms
teach you how to torture PE and hate yep
and judge they teach you how to pay the
bills at all that's some pity Asian moms
passive-aggressive no they're just
aggressive director you know this the
funny stereotype is this the stereotype
is like every love everyone else so I'm
thinking to Jewish friends they love
everyone are so like what like
subservient like they're so quiet and
like good I'm like you don't [ __ ]
know [ __ ] you don't know that's a
sizzler and I saw an older Asian couple
and the guy like I always was taught all
these like traditional norms the guy was
going up and grabbing the food it's a
buffet so you anybody could go up but he
wouldn't up got her food then he went up
got his food cuz he's in trouble it was
like yeah it says lose her spot it was
like okay he's in trouble one way to fix
this
yeah it was had never because I'm just
used to like you say it's supposed to be
like Oh Asian customs is the woman bears
down to the mail that's what people
think that's what people think bro but
they run everything and they're like Kim
jong-un do you guys hear that I hear the
sound of his pants being unzipped and
getting sucked off right now the more he
speaks the more leg slowly spread like a
blossoming flower in the morning like
you know this guy
yeah I collect look like a lettuce like
it's just slowly opening up this way
years famous yeah how's your mama now
she actually I was just talking to her
phone's got to be the splits she just
called me because they're taking her
medication that'll like help the rate of
the chemotherapy yeah young so it was
tough because I hadn't heard from her
for like three days were you alone or
someone helping her she has she has a
nurse who's not there 24 hours um but
like you know I had to realize like yo
she's sometimes gonna be busy like she's
not ghosted me and I was just you know
going through chemotherapy so she
apologized she laid I'm sorry you know I
couldn't call back and so I just give
her that space to kind of work through
her [ __ ] but she just called me and she
sounded stronger and sounds like the
medications working and [ __ ] it is she
still working no no she was right before
that's rough it was sudden this [ __ ] man
like she she went in she thought she had
a stomachache and then it turned out to
be cancer and had like she just takes
the robitussin that didn't work and now
this is what's so crazy and I'm kind of
been telling this story to people but
you know doctors thank you they just
[ __ ] shoot beyond a pale when they do
a diagnosis those Snapple ones because
they're like oh yeah it's looking like
stage 4 no Mike what the [ __ ] I'm in
Chicago like Stage four so how many
stages are there four there's no Stage
five no no no
I never studied cancer in debt I don't
know anyone that's until they're
ridiculous you're like senior know that
they say stage four or I'm all like okay
what does that mean what so yeah just
that's that's it so like they told me
that I was opposed to coming in Thursday
that was enough this was a month ago I
just I went I had to go that day cuz I'm
just like I can't be in [ __ ] Eagle
Rock what my mom
I have so I fly there they removed like
a 15 pound [ __ ] baby worth fluid from
her and in there like oh yeah just small
traces now I'm like [ __ ] you say it
stayed for like you don't say that
unless you know yeah that's true yeah I
mean thank God yes but like that was em
it's everyday talk but the way that
they're presenting it to other people
right it's like come on man yeah you
can't give me a heart attack
like just say we don't know our eggs
that you don't know yeah and [ __ ] or
do we think it might be but I think
that's their way of like being able to
provide good news
we're like they take you there
emotionally and then they bring it back
like what if that person is like oh my
god well what's the point of behind
negotiators actually that's like it's a
great negotiation tactic I feel like
this one movie villain I can't think of
who it is we kind of who kind of mini-me
meaning me or like Hans Gruber maybe I
don't know oh yeah I just think like
they oh they always overdo it so they
can bring you back and go that's the
best tactic in the world it's scary you
saw a bar later on it is for Disneyland
rides so I love it that they say like
hey it's gonna be 60 minutes to get in
line you're like that felt like 40
minutes that's cool for that but it's
your mom you talking about stage four
cancer you take a airplane you're like
the gimmick gimme my money back for for
buying the same day ticket says I wanna
play games
you just got airplanes be like hey just
tell me what some numbers up yeah just I
just waited it wasn't you rather have
their like all your mom got a tummy ache
and then later just kidding it was
cancer I'm rather them saying no say is
cancer say that we have some operate say
what it is but don't tell me it's the
end of the [ __ ] line and I'm in
California that's true cuz that's like
it's like hey she has four cats and you
can show up in her life it was just we
so glad you're here it's just okay this
is a social experiment you know we're
trying to promote more family you know
face to face and get to hospital is
about bringing families together hey
Claire look at that camera right there
just cancer it on you don't ever play
with me like that
million dollar deal and [ __ ] they're
like well what's really important your
mom or money
I left sent I mean without money my mom
she got pay for these treatments this
has been a month so this is like alright
this is all France's freshest but I was
just in Chicago second time last week
but isn't comedy awesome like to be able
to it's just another tool to cope the
dumbest thing about comedy be an artist
right or whatever is like whatever you
want there you can write your way out of
it
yeah you couldn't always you're history
you can own it you can tell it you can
create it you can embellish you can do
all these things with if you're not
getting booked enough write better jokes
if you're going through some weird write
a joke about it tell the story about it
the best thing is like if I write like
[Music]
like I write like a half-hour pilot or
something like that everything that I
can't say onstage this character can say
mmm you don't mean cancel character you
can sir
Jimmy which I think it's the baby I
didn't say it I thought I was effective
in the woods especially the Tiffany
Haddish
we ready a special that they had on
Netflix was that the first one I think
is the first one it was all the women
that came out on that did that I felt
like that applied all obliged to them
where they were just talking about their
truths coming out
but since it's through comedy I think
they were able to cope with a little bit
better because they were able to do that
is I mean I've never heard somebody say
you know what I don't want to laugh now
they don't want to hear a joke that's
not funny
but you always want to laugh you know I
mean that's the 10 years yeah
there was a friend of mine I mean we'll
miles who's very accomplished - he just
did the Comedy Central half hours and
rights for groaning and South Side and
we went to high school together in
college and he he started it and I was
like all right let me write some jokes
for you and some of the jokes didn't
really fit his personality
cuz he's were from opposite sides of
town so I went up to open mic tried it
and he was the problem the first
experience went well right Bob well the
same for me but because it went well I
was kind of [ __ ] hooked after that
you're like yeah and the energy the live
energy 25 minutes I looked at two
minutes I was almost but but to me it
was like two minutes probably felt like
an hour though when it's going well
you're just like damn I was [ __ ]
killer I may have in retrospect it's
always like in my mind is funnier than
it was but I knew I got laughs it's just
I [ __ ] fell in love right away it was
like immediate because it's nothing like
I'm making strangers laugh off some [ __ ]
I created which is kind of like a little
god complexity but it's real you know
the man like people I know sometimes I
laugh but I feel like your friends are
the hardest critics yep
or your wife oh that's the worst is your
wife can be your friend you've heard it
a million times it doesn't hit them the
same yeah it can't be I'm just way more
calm the more people the more
comfortable I am because the faces don't
distinguish themselves right so it's a
numbers game like you do it so much that
they're no longer like people it's just
like or like comedy crowds can be a
little insecure so like if this whole
side of the room is laughing and you not
you start laughing oh I want to be weird
and
laughs even if you don't think it's that
funny but if most of the room is
laughing you guys so it's like continues
really you're not a man like or if
nobody's laughing and you think
something is real funny people who laugh
like this you know maybe I'll cover
their mouth or like hold your hand
because they don't wanna seem weird if
they're the only one yeah we're very
social like that a gorilla is the same
way we're like when they interact with
humans they'll look to make sure like
anybody's looking at them like oh cool
let me like say what's up to this weird
human over here like they'll wait to
find the approval before they do
anything same way that we do that's why
we have like give myself yeah I thought
were just like even if you know homegirl
is like I think all my weird for talking
to this person same with my comedy yeah
I mean so they're self-conscious they
have they have social they're very
social animals
same with office office had the same
kind of thing not the same thing with
like interacting humans but like their
shoulder that they're yeah they're
social net what they do will be okay
with the people in there with you know
they rape though right they also do is
they they go to they're like they have
Dolphin gangs and then they steal the
girls from other tribes and then that
that's their sex and it's all species if
they're in the water and the dolphin is
around the dolphins gonna [ __ ] that
animal don't [ __ ] a starfish if they
know anything
I do love people cuz I yeah you don't
the people you know dolphins right
people because oh my god have you been
raped king of the hill where Hank what
I'm not there's a dolphin or was it
worth it what was the episode when he
got you got messed up by like how you
know you know say thank you say I know I
should so I think oh because could I saw
an episode now I was like oh snap they
really like do that kind of stuff and I
think I've looked it up and I was like
oh dude yeah that they do and I think
that something you're supposed to do
when you're like interacting with them
or petting them but let them [ __ ] you no
no no
you know no you cannot repeat too close
to him like don't cuz they finally can
they can't guess if this is the same
like a dog will come and like you to hug
your leg that kind of thing like they
tell you to be careful that when you're
in those pools mean like I see where all
stuff like that you know you've been as
a kid yeah before I yeah that's why I'm
saying now I can never go back
what is I still haven't found out a by
any of it what is it what are like black
what is it called back like this there's
very harmful to the animals I mean
that's one reason why that captivity
like yeah because captivity was one of
them that's reason why that worker
killed home girls cuz like they don't
like being there you know and that won't
play I think though girl had her her
foot like over the pool would average
like beating up snatched them straight
down to the bottom of the pool never
came back up again
you mean to tell me a killer whale
killer [ __ ] whale killer Yaga seal
yeah I believe that Wow we gotta be
careful will we name them in the smaller
with all the people that are haters I
will they've never seen the actual
SeaWorld show that [ __ ] was so good
hey cuz all the kids want to go to the
front glass and get splat yeah a little
Yanko thing a just flash come on shadow
give it to it oh come on
I'll come juice all the way no that's
not how to get back into signs like
humans
I need a money tree Orca just [ __ ]
you've just spitting out dollar bills
for me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]